I would like to introduce Jared Frieden
my partner and his esteemed panel who he
will introduce to talk about technology
thank you thank you Jeff okay well I am
super lucky to have a very esteemed
group of guests with me here today the
everyone on this panel is is a tactical
founder of a really successful company
everyone here has built like a really
cool company in a really amazing
technology organization we've changed
the name of the event for today it was
originally called a CTO advice and on
the advice of Lillian thank you so much
we have changed it to tactical founder
advice which i think is a better
description and I'd also like to thank
everyone on the startup school forum who
wrote in with questions for the panel we
posted a few weeks ago and solicited
questions we got over 150 responses so
thank you everyone who wrote in with
those questions we're gonna do our best
to cover as many of them as we can and
then at the end we'll open it up to the
in-person audience or some questions as
well okay so let's get started could we
start by having everyone introduce
themselves and tell us about your
company and about your technology like
what's your tech stack what's some of
the interesting technology that you
build how does your technology
organization look like today oh you
monster hello everyone my name is Ralph
Judy
I'm CTO and co-founder of plain grid
clean grid were 350 people based out of
Mission San Francisco we write beautiful
easy-to-use software for the 17 trillion
dollar construction industry so what
that looks like to you the analogy often
uses we're like github for construction
construction has blueprints blueprints
change rapidly version controls
extremely important if you have changes
that means there's issues that are
happening issues need to be tracked and
then we build collaboration tools the
top of that too as well as a lot of
other tools for the construction
industry that go into some deep jargon
our stack we're you know based on AWS we
used to be based on a variety of other
things we had to move everything into
AWS
over time on our back end mostly Python
on the back end that we've got some go
and other things and then one of our
challenges is we actually write native
for every platform so we've got iOS with
objective-c Android all Java and Kotlin
the web reacts and then windows we have
a full Windows app as well which has
done that hi everyone I'm Calvin French
Owen and CTO and co-founder of segment
segment is a single API to collect
organize and adapt all of your customer
data into hundreds of downstream tools
you might be using whether that's an
analytics tool like Google Analytics or
Mixpanel maybe a customer success tool
like gain site maybe an email tool like
customer i/o segments helps you collect
data from where it lives and get it
where it needs to be in terms of the
company overall we're a little over 300
people right now we have our
headquarters in San Francisco but we
also have offices in Vancouver New York
and Dublin and the engineering product
and design team which is kind of how we
build product here at segment is a
little over 80 or 90 right now in terms
of our tech stack we're also built
entirely atop of AWS in terms of how we
run our infrastructure we run on top of
ECS Amazon's container service and
pretty much all of our different
services our containerized today we're
running about 300 different micro
services which are kind of piping
together various kafka topics and
reading and writing transforming this
data getting it to where it needs to go
and our back-end is primarily written in
go good morning everyone so my name is
diana who i was the founder and CTO for
SEO reality and we're building the
backend for augmented reality and i say
i was because my company just got
acquired by Niantic the makers of
pokemon go so what we were building an
Escher and now we actually continue
doing it in Niantic is building this
back-end technology for augmented
reality to enable developers to build a
our experiences as easy as possible so
we handle all the complexity with the
computer vision
rhythms with all the interaction with
the backend all the hard parts of
getting things to render so that
developers could build easy a our apps
in minutes so that's what we do and we
provide a lot of advanced they are
features like multiplayer persistence
and cross-platform
so that is easy for developers are just
developing and let's say on unity and it
just works so in terms of tech stack has
been a bit of an adventure back at Asher
we were we had a service that was hosted
in AWS but that didn't matter too much
because we had everything in docker
containers now a Niantic is I think is
heavy user of Google Cloud so move
everything to Google Cloud but we have a
lot of the bulk of the code is actually
for us native means more C++ literally
because we is a lot more efficient for
us to write the code and a lot of the
algorithms once and then cross compile
it across all the architectures for
Android or iOS and even the back end so
that we run some of the CVL rails we
could prototype it in the phone and then
we could easily move them into the
server because our service actually also
written in C++ hi everyone I'm Lillian I
am CEO oh not CTO of second measure so
second measure we're about 50 people we
got started back in 2015 and we're based
in San Mateo what we do is we analyze
credit card data so basically we take
billions of credit card transactions and
try to build a daily view into the
public and private company performance
we analyze these billions of
transactions automatically every day and
just them clean them enrich normalize
them and then service that in a
front-end application for our clients
which include VC firms hedge funds and
big brands like blue apron or Spotify to
check trends do any sort of competitive
intelligence or customer intelligence so
we actually don't have a CTO so that's a
fun fact about us and that's why I'm
here on the panel
and myself and my co-founder actually
both technicals that's been really
pretty fortunate we don't have to deal
with as many of the challenges around
starting with non-technical founders so
our I mentioned that our team is about
50 people primarily technical so our
technical organization is about 30
people and that's actually split evenly
between data scientists and engineers
and that's probably something that makes
us unique is that our core product is
actually the data itself so our data
scientists and engineers have to
collaborate super closely on a day to
day basis and probably one of the things
that has technically been interesting is
a lot of our users want to explore and
dive deep into our data and building a
front-end that allows that flexibility
of exploration while still creating a
good user experience basically requires
us to figure out how to rapidly query
data and run really complex queries on
our back-end
yes about tech stock we're also
primarily on AWS so for our pipeline we
leverage services like lamda and spark
and then for our front-end we react
based and leveraged column columnar data
stores on the backend to service queries
so I think redshift awesome guys that
was super cool it's so cool the
diversity of different kinds of
technology organizations and products
that are here today okay so most of the
company is in start-up school are really
early so I want to take everyone here
back to their v1 the very first version
before you had actually shipped anything
tell us the story of how you built your
v1 who built it how did you built it how
long did it take you to build it and
what things went wrong in the process I
guess I'll start this is a great story
I've actually got my CEO and co-founder
over there watching me right now and um
so that's company hi Tracey yeah hey
Tracey how's it going
so that's that's where we started Tracy
told me about her idea of putting
blueprints on an iPad this was in 2011
right at the launch of the iPad so it
was very early for the technology and I
said yeah no problem I could put
blueprints on my PI it's like a PDF
that's no problem at all
so I was attempting to impress her
really quickly by putting blueprints on
an iPad and it turns out there was
actually some hard core challenges with
putting these giant images on a really
low computer availability on the iPad
there's no graphics chip at the time so
basically these are 20,000 pixel images
and they would just crash or overrun the
video memory and they're in PDF which is
a kind of painful format to deal with so
the first prototype sucks um is really
slow and that actually told me that
there's something real meaty here
there's something that's actually a
challenge and it took me about a month
to write the second prototype based off
some my background actually I used to
work at Pixar so I had some graphics
experience there didn't use any
proprietary stuff but use some
off-the-shelf computer graphics
knowledge to write the first blueprint
viewer that ever ran on mobile so that
was our first prototype back then and I
think the best thing I remember back on
it is um the only thing we really
focused on the first prototype was what
was technically impossible there was no
way you could load blueprints onto an
iPad at the time and that was our
prototype which meant that all the data
got there by side loading which meant
there was no web interface and the
little crappy web interface we had had a
delete button right next to a publish
button that was not a pixel apart and
there was no confirmation on the delete
button so we actually as a team we
managed everything on the back end we
kind of like behind the curtains loaded
all the documents for our first 30 or 40
customers but they all they saw was the
the pot the prototype that was fast and
did what they thought it would they
never saw the man behind the curtain so
to speak so that's all the story of our
first prototype cool um I'll share a
little bit of a story of our v1 and then
maybe our v1 next I think for those of
you has seen the startup school talk
where my co-founder Peter talks about
finding product market fit he goes into
this story and way more detail than I
could today but I can share a little bit
of our journey so when we first started
we were in
oh I see 2011 class which sounds like a
dinosaur now in terms of YC years yeah
but at the time we were actually
building something completely different
from segments today we were building
this classroom lecture tool which would
help professors get feedback about what
their students were thinking in the
middle of class we were students at the
time we figured hey like this is seems
like a great ideas professors will
sometimes go on for five minutes and
they'll lose the entire class and the
class gets confused and just waste
everyone's time let's solve that problem
we built it out over the course of the
summer and we deployed it back in Boston
in the fall and the whole thing just
kind of crashed and burned
like students would go to Facebook
YouTube Wikipedia like in retrospect all
the things that you would assume college
students would do if they have a laptop
in front of them in a lecture but we
didn't quite see it that way
so we started looking around for a new
idea because we've just raised a seed
round and we say okay what are the
problems that we have with this college
lecture tool and one of them was that we
couldn't answer questions about how
people were using our tool we can tell
you how a college students at Harvard
we're using the tool differently than
students at MIT or we couldn't tell you
how anthropology classes used it
differently than biology classes and so
we switched again to something which
also we don't do today but effectively
it was a competitor to Mixpanel or
amplitude is this tool that would allow
you to cluster your users by different
rules and break them up into segments
which is where the name came from and
from there you could then reach out to
them or figure out what you're most
engaged users were doing and so we built
out that system for about 15 months the
whole time we were doing revs on the
backend infrastructure we were building
it out and we're trying to get users and
no one wanted our tool and so we arrived
fifteen months later we actually moved
back to the Bay Area after living in
Boston for a year we go and talk to PG
and we tell them about kind of our whole
saga that's been running for the past
year and a half
and you listen to our story and he
listens to everything that we've done
and when we're finished he just sort of
pauses I think it was maybe 400 feet out
there walking around the roundabout he
says wow so you just burned half a
million dollars and you're still at
square one they're just like yes he said
well on the plus side you still have
some runway left so try again like want
something new and at the time we had
this internal tool that we had been
using as kind of a growth hack to get
ourselves more users and the whole idea
was that you would use the same API to
send us data as you would send to
Mixpanel KISSmetrics Google Analytics
all these other tools and people
actually liked that single API and they
were contributing to this open source
library and github and starring it and
using it and so my co-founder Ian said
hey why don't we turn this into a
product
why don't we launch this and see what
happens and my co-founder Peter said oh
that's the worst idea I've ever heard it
will never work he's CEO now but he's
seen the light and so I he said okay
I've got to figure out a way that we can
test this idea incredibly quickly so we
cleaned up the library and we launched
it on Hacker News and to our surprise it
actually got about a thousand stars that
first day I'm github and so our real v1
was that first week taking that library
and we basically just had a landing page
up which said hey if you're interested
in a hosted version of this leave your
email and about 500 people left their
email and we built out that v1 over
about a week where just everyone was in
Mad hackathon mode and building out the
product which we launched a week later
and so today I think there's actually no
parts of that product which still live
on today but it was enough to get us
kind of the seed of product market fit
and then start getting us a user base so
one week is the short one week one week
everybody hear that one week ok that's
kind of amazing one week sir story is
definitely more than one week so me and
my co-founder have been thinking of
building different things and one of the
technology trends that we really saw was
he
it comes from a robotics background with
a lot of experience with slam slam is
this album called simultaneous
localization and mapping and it's one of
the core algorithms that run today in AR
which helps tell where your camera
position is while you also build this
map of the world so what happened is
there's this category of algorithms that
have been used mostly for robotics now
AR had been kind of tried and many times
but never really being picked up there's
AR with markers and that never really
took off and then we thought about why
do we bring these algorithms and run
them on the phones and we got to the
point where we thought we could do it
because the computation at that point
with phones for example for iPhone 7 has
the same competition actually as a
MacBook Pro from 2013 so that's you
think about that that's kind of amazing
in terms of all the trends with Moore's
law and some of the ones with power
efficiency and compute so we decided to
go do it so we were at that time I was
actually still working and I was leading
a data science team back then and say
okay I'll do it because I was thinking
of doing some transition and I was
working part time with another engineer
and this one of the engineers that that
we kind of got excited to work with us
so we struggle a lot to try to get a
version working the first was very duct
tape and it wasn't very encouraging it
was only working at five frames per
second which is terrible because if you
want a good AR experience the whole
thing is that you need it to render
nicely and be at least 30 frames per
second so that was very discouraging in
a sense and then because it was all kind
of put together this and then we started
kind of really removing all the research
code out and then it started working and
seeing a lot of promise and it was
running then at at least 30 frames per
second and note that when we were
working on this was at least about a
year and a half before air kid had
launched and then we were excited about
this so we were both very more from a
technology side so we don't know product
market fit way to go with this so we had
to find the market so the exercise we
did is actually we went in an interview
a bunch of
people that we thought would use it and
we found a really good for it with
gaming so we decided to focus on that
and that was sir
YC application and the thing that really
took us and this took off and this is
actually I guess a good story too is the
first day of YC Apple announced air kit
which is basically what we had built and
that was sort of a moment of truth for
us it's sort of this really moment where
you are looking at yourself and it is
really go flight-or-fight so we decided
why not let's just take on Apple so we
decided to just double down and we had
this idea that the start wasn't just on
the device which we had all our demos
and Technology was just working on the
phone we didn't have anything on the
backend yet so back in YC we got it
working with a back-end and also with
Android and basically accelerating the
roadmap that we thought it was about a
year shrink it and got it done in three
months and that was the thing that once
we put it out there and let people sign
up if they were interested we go got
about a thousand developers signed up in
about a week so they find okay I think
we found something and then after that
we got a lot of interest and among those
Niantic was one and the story is we got
acquired later
so how long was it from the time that
you started working on the like original
slam algorithms until you had it like a
working product in users hands so we
were not really working full time it was
probably about a year of part time and
even by the time was part time wasn't
really working so when full time I took
another six months of just me and
another engineer to do it and then
during the summer YC we hired two more
engineers and that's when we were able
to really accelerate and get it working
well cool so for us our v1 probably took
assuming full-time two or three months
to build and I actually would say that
most of that time was just figuring out
what our product was going to be we knew
that the
that we were working on is gonna be
really interesting initially we were
focused on investors basically trying to
get them an information edge on sort of
any investment decisions that they're
making whether that be hedge funds focus
on public markets or VCS focus on
private markets we ran through a few
ideas we're like hey do these investors
want predictions we they just want to
know how like this company public
company's quarterly sales are gonna hit
and the short answer is yes but but no
that doesn't really seem like a really
sort of sustainable business model so
then we shift it a little bit like okay
maybe these investors really really want
to go deep and they just want to cut
data any way they want so we put
something together really quickly put
that in front of some of our friends
your investors and found out very
quickly through some white user testing
that that was way too overwhelming our
users wanted some guidance so what
ultimately landed on is we needed to
build our own self-service platform
where we can apply our opinions around
how our customers should be viewing this
data and getting quick access to
insights so once we figure that part out
I was actually pretty quick so my
co-founder focused on building the
analytics product piece so the the front
end application and I'd say you know and
together we kind of focus together we
built sort of the data pipeline and sort
of the transformations on the data but I
think some important choices that we
made early on is and maybe some that you
guys are facing right now is what
technology do you want to use like what
do you want to build this in ultimately
we decided to build our first
application in groovy using the Grails
framework which is very not shiny and
not that many people are doing that but
that was actually the code that we had
the most experience in so my co-founder
Mike had built large production scale
system servicing hundreds of thousands
of concurrent users and pretty much
within a week had
the bones of the application and kind of
like some of these other stories here
like none of us it sounds like are
running rv1 anymore so it's more
important in the early days to be able
to iterate quickly and usually that
comes from using the technology that you
know the best building things in a
modular way such that once you actually
find that product market fit and know
what your audience needs then you can
focus on that area and actually select
tech technologies that are best fit for
that problem awesome
okay so I'm gonna go next to the very
top voted question from the startup
school forum which is about the
trade-off between engineering best
practices like good test coverage and
security and scalability and he done and
see versus writing code as quickly as
possible and shipping something so can
everyone talk about how you made that
trade-off for your v1 and then how it's
evolved since then and sort of like the
timetable of its evolution as your
company grew and those things became
presumably more important and just to
mix it up let's try flipping the order
and we'll start with Lilly in this time
sure
so speed is paramount nobody's gonna pay
you for having excellent test coverage
so in the early days the it's it's you
definitely want sort of the bit of like
what you need right so it was that's the
risk to your business around sort of
security and not having things working
and obviously you want your whatever you
build to run every day you don't want to
be fixing it breaking all the time and
not actually building but really it is a
balance and I do believe that initially
it's more important to have that speed
of development and incorporate
constantly testing and incorporating the
learnings into your product than it is
to have like the most robust
most scalable product great you're
trying to find something that people
will pay you money for ourselves a real
problem and that takes time and a lot of
iteration that has definitely evolved
since we got started you know once you
find product market fit a lot of these
problems change you know your system
gets more complex your team grows you
have a lot more people contributing code
a lot more ways for your systems to
break a lot more users who are relying
on your product so for us the way that
manifested itself is yeah we started
writing unit tests to verify each
engineer would be verifying that you
know their code works then we introduced
CIN CD to make sure that that could work
with the whole system our director of
engineering who leads our engineering
organization started developing and
formalizing our best practices around
like code reviews testing etc in
defining those processes and then
finally building some more controls
directly into our system to make it
harder to break things and specifically
like what was the rough timeline for
those things like are we talking about
like two months after launch two years
after launch
so I'd say most of that stuff I was just
talking about happened probably the last
year to a year and a half so and that's
how many years after about a year and a
half after launch and the main reasons
for that again were the growth and the
complexity of our systems and you know
our techno are technical staff tripled
in the last year so just that alone
introduces a lot more need for process
in our case it was always about trying
to get to MVP that was reasonably
walking wet well and all that was
definitely duct tape code there is
nothing that I'd be proud of it's just
Frankie's I had put together and barely
working as much as possible so we were
there even when we
kind of private launch in a sense when
we that the private beta and got
customers who kind of sign up and we
were actually had a beta a private beta
that we had some number of game
developers working with us and that was
also the duck tech code
the only time we started actually having
all the best practices is actually once
we joined I antic because now we have to
integrate into the games which pokomoko
has hundreds of millions of users so
we're bearing ourselves to get a lot of
the we pretty much we wrote the whole
codebase none of what we had before is
there it's all rewritten through pair of
do that that expect that number of users
cool I think for us at segments there
are kind of three distinct phases of our
development I'd say the first one was
when we were in full hackathon mode
right where we definitely didn't have
any tests no CI
we're I'd say there was an 80% chance
that we were just going to throw it out
two weeks later because it wasn't going
to stick and then we were going to move
on to the next thing I think because we
had been burned so much by building out
all of this infrastructure and investing
a lot of these ways to provision your
infrastructure and write tests and spin
up different new services over the past
year and a half and it really I gotten
us nowhere
we had no users it has created this like
pretty aligning homing instinct for us
where we just said no matter what the
only thing that matters is getting users
at this point in the game so that's
where where we started and I think that
lasted us probably for about the first
nine or ten months where we were just
focused on rapid iteration getting more
users making sure that we didn't run out
of money and then the whole thing
wouldn't be been mattered I think from
there the the first phase that then
shifted was when we brought on our first
engineer TJ Wright for those of you who
know are involved with the node
community
TJ is one of the best engineers I think
I've ever worked with I think 90% of
node shops run on some part of his code
and he basically came in two segments
and he looked around at well this mess
that we created the product that we
created any
said well there's no way for me to work
in this like I have a horrible time
onboarding I think it took him a week to
get his entire laptop set up and so we
kind of moved from this point where the
entire development team shares the same
tube of toothpaste to now starting to
have more and more engineers involved
with the project and when that happened
it really stepped up our game in terms
of testing in CI
and just reproducibility when it came to
running the builds and running the stack
because suddenly we had to expand
outside of just the four of us and then
I think so maybe that period lasted
another two or three years probably in
the past two three or four years from
now or from this point in time we've
gone through another shift where we've
started thinking a lot more about
end-to-end testing security kind of best
practices around handling all of our
customers data and the real reason for
that is that now we actually have a
pretty significant amount both like
revenue and customers and reputation to
lose from day one we had no users so it
didn't matter if the whole thing went
down for a day or hours or whatever was
just the calculus didn't make sense
there but today we have thousands of
customers who are relying on segments to
publish their data to not lose it to
treat it and handle it securely and so
for us the investment makes way more
sense and and that that last period like
roughly what scale did you have to reach
before you started thinking seriously
about those things yeah it's a good
question I think when we started having
enterprise customers who are paying
north of six figures per year that's
when it started to shift and we started
thinking oh we really have to take care
and how we're handling this data because
these customers are really depending on
this to power their business so I think
my story's a little different than the
other panelists this might be
interesting I would say all three of
those different facets I think I heard
security I heard scalability and I heard
engineering best practices we really
have to treat them independently at
plain grid klinger's used to build all
in
most most hospitals most jails most
heavy civil roadwork were used on all
the tech campuses all of the different
government buildings that go up so
obviously security from day one I mean
that's that's key to us so we had no
choice but to always be super conscious
of security and scalability for that
matter because our customers the only
way we're useful is if we're used to
build the project like we're the
replacement for blueprints which means
in construction if we're not working
properly like no one builds and not
building for a dam construction can
seriously impact the bottom line of
these businesses so for us the first two
security and scalability we're always
key scalability is a challenging one
because it's I don't know I'm not sure
if there's a way to do it without it
being kind of reactionary you either
over engineer everything and then you
maybe never get a product to market or
you eventually have to deal with scaling
issues and for us we tried to architect
it in such a way that we would last
through the foreseeable future the
foreseeable future would come and some
customer would find the first kind of
flaw in the scalability and we're used I
mean our to give you an idea of the
scale we've probably about we've
customers with projects that are like
500,000 blueprints with a ton of changes
and maybe over 5 million annotations on
one project and we're work we work
offline as well so this is all
downloaded onto a cache on the device we
can actually our physical size on an
iPad can take up like a hundred
gigabytes for certain projects so we
have like all kinds of scaling issues
we've had to approach and we always try
to balance it between engineering like a
year ahead of time but not maybe three
years ahead of time which is a trade-off
so you know find that trade-off yourself
I remember when we were in - I see we
had all these stories of companies that
had built the most ironclad architecture
and just never had a product to market
so that was on our minds while we were
building that for engineering best
practices are v1 some of that code still
exists in the product today so some of
the code I wrote for v1 still there I
would say it's probably our measure of
technical debt as an engineering
organization so that's humbling but at
the same time like I've seen some
developers and you know we're fully uh
you know we do everything cool now see
ICD
we run integration tests we've got a UI
testing team so this is feedback I'm
giving from the past but you know if
you're a experienced developer it's
pretty hard to write spaghetti Kraft
code you know it's actually challenging
most experienced developers and
experienced some people are just really
good from the get-go it's normally
something through time and writing a lot
of production products that you just
generally learned the tricks of not
writing spaghetti code pretty quickly
and you know some of that code runs
without heavy testing the other thing to
mention is to properly scale test our
product it doesn't I mean it would take
days during the integration test to
download and upload all the data so we
really have a lot of functional testing
to help us double-check but the thing
I've noticed with UI and unit tests is
we're big fan of unit tests for a big
fan of tester and development I've
definitely seen developers write the
most spaghetti test frameworks and the
most spaghetti tests where they're just
testing their mocks and they're doing
this in the middle of a production
environment you know like a production
need for release and they spent so much
time writing these unit tests that
actually were not testing anything
rather than getting the product out the
door so engineering best practices are
great there's a trade-off between
writing a lot of tests and writing good
code from the get-go
so speaking of test-driven development a
lot of the questions were about the
various engineering methodologies agile
development lean startup test-driven
development extreme programming how do
you guys think about those do you adhere
to any particular methodology in your
company I would describe us as agile ish
so we do not fully adopt any of those
methodologies basically we find what
works well for our team and aren't super
dogmatic about you know is this agile or
is this not you know we run sprints we
have daily stand-ups so we have some
elements incorporated in our development
but I think kind of with anything you
know a lot of these problems you're
going to be solving a lot of problems
for organization and you have to kind of
find what works best for you and so I
think it makes sense to take bits and
pieces
that work for you and adapt it to your
organization and then I guess it's just
the one other thing I'd mentioned on
this is as you grow a big a big
challenge is just constantly evolving
how you work right so it's very
different to work on a small team before
where everyone kind of knows everything
and everyone everything is then
everyone's heads versus a team of 30 or
50 or for some of us you know hundreds
that is very different so you kind of
constantly need to be assessing is this
style of working or this methodology is
this right for this stage of the company
yeah I think the point of evolving the
process is something we've been doing a
lot so back when we were that's chair we
were only with four engineers and me
building the product so back then it was
very messy we're just trying to move as
fast as possible really so zero
documentation everything was kind of
whiteboards and everyone kind of could
handle everything in their heads and and
build it out and in terms of we didn't
really do Sprint's because they think
the some engineers are even quite liked
it as much and there were just too many
big tasks and we just trusted different
individuals to go and tackle kind of one
area and then we would integrate it but
now things are very different as we
hired I think team is triple ready in
the past eight months for the AR
platform product when you have a bigger
team you definitely need a lot more
process to be able to be efficient and
communicate because you don't want to
duplicate and not everyone knows
everything and the system grows in a lot
of complexity so we went from zero
documentation to a lot more when from we
used to have a little bit CI but now is
very much of a CI that actually builds
to all the architectural flavors to
linux mac OS android x86 Android arm iOS
etc and actually runs all the tests in
all of them and actually catches a lot
of bugs and we tests we have coverage
and all those things but we also have to
train and get the team to be ok with
having more process so now we do not
quite like a sprint but we do weekly
planning for the week and then we
reconvene and I think the teams are kind
of breaking break it down into sub teams
that work and people kind of float in
and out of their fan focus on areas we
split in three main focuses one is sort
of the back end folder work with the
back end I lower the work on the client
to make it cross-platform the unity API
is and the other the big one is bringing
a lot of the computer vision algorithms
to production so the funny thing is that
everyone in the team has ended up being
and trained up to be a computer vision
out engineer because that's sort of the
core we have CV algorithms on the server
let's see the algorithms in the client
and the core algorithms that run so
there's been this how it kind of shaped
up to be but we don't really have a per
se a process where we do right now
Niantic that's okay our so now we have
all cares as well per quarter so now
we're starting to plan longer longer and
have ideas of before you still have like
a rough idea where things would go but
now this this and this and this yeah for
us we don't have any set process that
teams have to follow at segments kind of
individual engineering teams sort of
like what Spotify does are able to self
organize they're able to run however
they want they want to do Sprint's at
school they want to use JIRA they can do
that if they want to use asana whatever
it is they're allowed to run however
they'd like to run the one thing that
we've introduced over the past two years
similarly the okay our model for those
of you are familiar and this was a model
that was developed at Google it's a idea
of O's or objectives and then key
results so you have your one objective
where you're trying to go and then key
results that are supposed to be
objective measures of how you get there
such if you do every K R then it adds up
to the full objective and so those are
something that we do on a company-wide
basis every single topic team in the
company gets together and puts together
their ok ours
they say one week before each quarter
and then for that three-month period
they're just executing on that plan and
some teams grade those on a weekly basis
and check in and say how am i doing
against these goals some teams grade
them on a monthly basis it kind of
doesn't matter but at the end of the
quarter
every team is saying hey here's how well
I did against my stated goals separately
for the teams that I work with and
particular we end up running kind of
just a weekly meeting where at the
beginning of the week we end up planning
out what we want to get done and then we
have kind of a daily stand up I honestly
don't care too much about the content
for those meetings so long as we're
always discussing the most important
problems we're pretty big believers that
the tools and process should be there to
serve us not the other way around
my experience at plain grid echoes all
the other panelists it's agile ish
self-organizing every team can choose
the tools that they want maybe some
things that'd be helpful to you from the
beginning some things we've always found
that's been very huge useful in every
engineering team are again the daily
stand-ups you've got to communicate on a
daily basis as engineers sometimes it
can be a little difficult to want to
communicate every day and not just
program when you wake up but that 15
minutes and you can do it remotely as
well over slack or something has always
been really helpful in just kind of
unblocking people time boxing I mean I
think that a lot of these management
practices all roll up into some abstract
philosophies and sprints or timebox
methods where you're just not going to
work on something infinitely that's very
helpful to kind of keep people's
realities in check because often
estimates can be off and you know
sometimes what we thought was going to
take us a week can take us a month
myself included so time boxing is a good
way to keep keep categories of that I'd
also say some other light weight
management techniques you can probably
employ right now and your team is
probably one to ones weekly one to ones
just make sure if you're talking to
people in a group and you're having
stand-ups make sure you have some time
to actually connect with people
individually and get to learn more about
their wants their needs their emotions
and their careers that's great guys okay
so now I want to change topics to the
right way to work with non-technical
co-founders and I think the topic that
came up most commonly in the startup
school forum was the one that ralph
alluded to which is how to deal with the
deadlines and timeframes particularly
with non-technical co-founders and I
think particularly in the in the early
days so does any
have thoughts on that any any orders get
I'll volunteer for this since my
technical non-technical co-founder is
staring at me over there um a few a few
ideas here if you've got someone that's
really non-technical and I'm not saying
my co-founders really non-technical I'm
sure she can use your computer but you
know if it's really non-technical this
is an amazing testing opportunity for
you I mean I remember I would write this
software and I'd be so happy about it
and I'd hand it to her and as soon as
she touched it it would break I mean I
don't know what she shook the iPad she
rotated it three times but she had a way
to break the stuff I wrote and that was
amazing for testing in the beginning so
that's one way to engage your non
technical co-founder you eventually have
to learn how to start pouting your
deadlines that's really hard to do I
never got very good at this I'm always
optimistic even to this day I'm like oh
yeah that's gonna take me a week so I
never really got good at this I'm just
aware that I'm optimistic about it and
then I'm always kind of off by week and
she's aware of that as well
so eventually I've talked to other
engineering leaders they keep two books
they keep like a separate set of books I
talked to their their technical
co-founders non-technical co-founders
about say okay here's the deadlines here
and then you have another set of books
that's actually when you think you're
gonna get the job done I think one thing
that can be really helpful is having a
process some very lightweight process of
like here's where we're like testing and
then here's release because often some
people might not realize that iOS has a
release cycle that's not controlled by
the developers it's controlled by Apple
so you got to pad that into your plan
you have to plan a little bit so I found
that a little bit of project management
goes a long way when you're dealing with
a non-technical co-founder and even
better if they're good at project
management that's a great place to
employ them as well so all of my
co-founders are technical so we didn't
really run into this problem in the
early days kind of everyone's like oh
yeah I know what's happening here
if it slips we know exactly why it
wasn't as big of an issue I found more
recently with deadlines kind of the
trick that I've started using is in
one-on-ones actually asking each person
what they think will happen over the
next three or four weeks and when I find
asking one to one is that one people
don't anchor against each other's
answers so you get a very unbiased view
and it like forces each person to think
about the
your term future what's going to happen
and second each person is much more wary
of the parts that they didn't work on
and so you get kind of a sense of like
where there might be trouble spots and
typically the end results is sort of
like a wisdom of the crowds where it's
kind of the average of all three or four
answers and so I've started using that
as a way to get a better sense of
deadlines where each person has their
prediction or mental model of what's
going to happen and then you kind of
average them all out to where it should
be um well I guess in my case my
co-founder didn't work in engineering or
build products or shaped products mostly
just in research so we've been doing
mostly a PhD so in that sense it's kind
a little bit you know technical in a
sense that not having experience of
building and shipping products it's
mostly just kind of the algorithm side
so there was a bit of that work to kind
understand why certain things take long
and why they need to be built a certain
way but at some point it was more he
just letting me handle all of that and
he got engaged mostly on the external
communications business trying to find
partners and all that so that's what
happened sometimes that could be the
split where as the technical founder you
end up owning the product and a lot of
development and having clear
communications and at least try to set
expectations that with deadlines that's
the hard part is always I think this is
always a trade-off between engineering
and product and business right the
trade-off on when to get things and be
able to communicate that clearly so my
co-founder is technical so I don't have
much to offer here not much to add
either on the deadlines and time
estimates to do your best guess do some
padding I'd say one thing kind of on the
non-technical front though that I do
think is worth mentioning is so you know
today a lot of you are probably building
your products and in writing code
especially if you're one of the
technical co-founders at least in my
experience that changes
so I pretty much stopped contributing to
our code base about a year into the
company and it's for us kind of as
leaders well I can't speak for all of us
but at least for me there's a pretty big
shift that happens once you start
gaining traction where it's less about
building a product for a market and
finding that fit and it shifts more into
turn like building an organization and a
company and a system like this system of
humans who are going to build something
long-lasting and great without a lot of
your involvement so I guess what I'm
trying to say is you know at some point
you may end up doing a lot more
non-technical
things so get ready for that yeah that's
great ok so a lot of the companies in
start-up school are at the phase where
they are trying to figure out the right
way to structure their early engineering
team if they want to hire people locally
if they want to hire people remotely if
they want to hire only employees who
work full-time or if they want to hand
off pieces of the product to contractors
or or to to third-party development
firms can you guys talk about how you
would think about that if you were
starting a company
now advice that you give them I think
this is going to be the last question
then we're going to open it up to the
audience I can start so we did not start
with contractors we started by building
like hiring full-time employees I think
the main guidance I would give here is
you are building a product in a company
and you're developing these core
competencies I'd say for the most part
like if you end up contracting that out
you're actually not just contracting out
through that technology expertise but
you're learning a lot in these early
days of what's going to work for your
clients wouldn't like what's the what
the product actually is and so moving
that sort of having that external to
your company I think is a really big
loss in the early days just in terms of
all that knowledge I could see an
argument if you're just like
getting off the ground and you're doing
contracting kind of as a way to evaluate
potential new hires I could see that
definitely being a path but again that
sort of with the intention of building
your team on outsourcing front I think
it's a similar thing of you really need
to look at like what is your core
competency that's what you're investing
in what's your IP you don't want to
outsource that at some point if you do
you're pretty much just a marketing
company and so I'd say if you are if
different business models might have
different requirements so for some of
you it may make sense to outsource a
large part of what you're building but
for us we have experimented a little bit
with outsourcing
I'd say our approach has really been to
make sure those projects are very well
defined and not on the critical path so
that we can experiment it is a different
type of project to manage sort of
outsource Talent and that way you can
sort of learn see if that works for your
for your business and if it does great
if it doesn't it's it's fine was there
also a question about remote local
versus remote employees I think that
depends on what type of culture you want
to build so for us we was really
important for us to have our team
together so we hired a local team and
then sort of in the last year so we have
actually started tapping into remote
engineers there's definitely like you
know a little bit of a culture shift
with that we're still predominantly
local but there are a lot of advantages
including being able to tap into other
talent pools and it has actually turned
out to be a really good forcing function
for documentation right explaining your
code explaining your decisions which is
good for a number of reasons including
just like as you grow communication is
one of the harder problems you have to
solve so I think for us because so much
of the core that technology is what our
company is we didn't quite outsource any
of that we did contract people
as more of an interview process so we
would work with and contact someone for
a month before we gave them an offer so
that's what we did but that we did
outsource more things that we really
thought they were not essential to her
company for example building 3d models
some of the design some of the actually
writing technical documentation at some
of it website things that were we could
do it if we had the time I wanted to
we knew we could do it stuff like I
could build a website but our time was
better spent on that core text so those
sort of things we did outsource and in
terms of remote versus local because
everything was so complex with what we
build we chose the culture to be more
all on-site and to this day we still are
building the team locally but I think
you could handle a lot of stories of
companies that do remote but you have to
kind of start remote first cool yeah I
can share a little bit from our story so
in the very early days we basically only
hired full-time folks we did an
experiment with contractors kind of the
only case where we'd outsource is when
eight of us could take some piece of
infrastructure that we're building or
like some new product feature and we
could build on top of that I think that
was still probably the right move
especially in the early days it feels
like a start-up is really fragile and
you want a bunch of people who were just
all pointed in the same direction and
really kind of in it for the long haul
on the local versus remote piece we
actually started hiring pretty much only
remote people we're really involved with
a lot of different open-source
communities on github
particularly there were some node in the
very early days some JavaScript ones
component etc and so these were people
who we had been working with and
collaborating with for years at this
point who then when we were ready to
start hiring we just said hey which you
like to work more closely together I
think it came with its own set of
trade-offs on the plus side we had
access to these people who were insanely
talented not in the San Francisco Bay
Area but who were used to working with
us already and who we very clear
like built an insane amount of value for
segments
I think the trickier part for us to get
right was around the communication piece
and all kind of being pointed in the
same direction from a product
perspective so while we grew remote from
about the first 10 or 15 hires we then
only grew locally through about the next
70 and then only recently started
opening remote backup and I think now
it's because we actually have enough
bandwidth to create a really good remote
culture where we're putting an emphasis
on that documentation that communication
piece and we're actually really able to
hire folks who have been working
remotely for years as well some really
good advice given on this panel so far I
think the trade offs are anything for
you to keep in mind the most I was
thinking back towards contractors and
I'll tell you a quick story of a
contractor our first two hires were
actually as I was thinking about it
contractors one of them helped us
organize our bills and our like kind of
office stuff and the other one helped us
develop some technology someone I worked
with when I used to work at Johns
Hopkins and even though he was a
contractor at first he actually you know
we needed money to pay him because he
was my friend
so we paid him in equity and he joined
us as our first engineer eventually and
helped us build some really core
technology for our company and really
was a great addition to playing grid so
I think that even though I wouldn't
suggest hiring a contractor immediately
we just did what was right for us at our
company size and what we needed right
then was like heli I need this kind of
right some stuff for me and he'll take
equity as payment wonderful because I
don't got anything else to pay man so I
mean I think just be open hearted with
what you think is needed for your
business right then no there's a lot of
trade-offs with contractors the other
thing to note is this was my friend
we've had contractors have hired as well
there's this ignorant feeling I can't
even now I feel it when you hire a
contractor that's like oh great I don't
want to manage this person and that is
so not true
management of contractors is significant
time for you as a founder that is not a
free hire it sometimes is worse actually
it's more management time for a
contractor than a full-time employee so
keep that in mind as well as the remote
thing this is also an interesting topic
when we started our company we tried to
aim to have people in San Francisco but
yet I realize actually as Kofi
we split off for like months at a time
we'd be like oh you know I'm gonna go
back to Chicago for a month and then you
know one of my co-founders to work out
of Chicago for a month or two and that
was totally cool as well we've gone back
and forth on this over our eight years
over and over again between allowing
remote not allowing remote allowing
remote when it's a friend or a really
good you know best in class I see that
can really develop a lot of things now
we're completely open as a company it
doesn't matter we hire managers remote
we hire local you know designers
products everyone doesn't really matter
we're just looking for the best talent
we can get so I think the best advice
you've gotten already is just do what's
right for you at the size of your
company and know that there's trade-offs
with all these decisions but there's no
easy answer for any of these questions
great okay I think we've got time for
one or two questions from the audience
questions questions one over there you
okay I'm just going to repeat the
question so everyone can can hear it um
if you were going to start another
company now what would you do to
accelerate the development process any
takers yeah sure I mean I think we spent
too much time building technology in my
on my side to try to really get that
product market fit as as soon as
possible
and it's a challenge in terms of the
areas that you pick because if you're in
a kind of frontier tech space with like
AR VR or this summer biotech those lead
time could be really long and think
about what kind of company you want to
build I'd say get in front of users all
the time find your user base it's really
it's actually a lot harder to build a
product in this vacuum where you're just
like in your head maybe your ID ating
with your co-founder and you're like
what if we do this what if we do this
these all sound great no this idea
sounds bad but it's like way easier to
just put it in front of somebody and
have them say this is great or this
sucks that feedback loop is invaluable
yeah echo the sentiment on users 100%
get out in front of them start showing
things to them start
make sure your digging deep to make sure
that you're really solving their problem
I think if I were to start again today
actually I'd build two or three versions
which I just intended to throw away
maybe this is biased on probably prior
experience but I think the fact that you
can get reps and a very safe manner
where then when you're really ready to
start you can just kind of go nuts
building out the v1 I think is really
powerful you know I love mobile
development
I love Swift I love Kotlin but I don't
think I would choose to have to write
for different platforms if I was going
to write again I probably would have
pick one of the cross-platform
development libraries I don't know which
is best they all you'd have to tell me
if anyone has like after this come your
strong opinions at which one of this is
best they all seem to have trade-offs
probably the best advice I could give
though as I'd stopped coding a little
bit earlier and I would start hiring a
little bit earlier because I think
there's a lot of me that wanted to
passionately write those features and if
I instead been passionately hiring other
developers we would have you know we
would have built faster I feel
interesting okay one more question over
there and your driving features given by
the users what would be the
communication style get them in front of
the users bringing them to the meetings
get them over the phone well then give
the questions you know kind of set it up
a little bit where you're trying to bait
the users into giving the feedback that
you're looking for or you won't get the
feedback you're looking for and maybe
there's some adjustment there too so get
them in front of users as much as you
can that's the most powerful tool you
have my opinion okay thank you all so
much this was great
[Applause]
you
you